the Chinese leadership deeply
understands The Kinks in our armor they
have a word for Western wokeness bitu
literally refers to woke white people in
the United States and other Western
countries and they use it to laugh at us
but now they're using that Progressive
front to actually co-opt companies that
criticize relentlessly the United States
over black lives matter or whatever the
NBA is in this category but they don't
say a peep in China in fact they
supplicate to China they lie prostrate
like lap dogs to their CCP overlords
while consistently biting the United
States in the process and that creates a
false moral equivalence between Chinese
nihilism and let's call it Western
idealism